In the Blue Ridge
Mountains, Eustace
is taking stock of his assets
in a bid to raise a lot of cash
fast.
Hey, man.
- Doing all right, Scott?
- I'm good.
How about yourself?
Pretty good.
Scott Beam is an antique
dealer specializing
in vintage farm equipment.
The two seater buggy
dates back to 1890
and was once used for day
to day horse drawn travel.
Let's get it right out here
where you can see it better.
Course, the more I see it, it
might change my mind on this.
I like it.
How much can you give
for something like this
and make a little profit?
Lookin' maybe 18.
I don't know if I can
let it go for 18, Scott.
How about $2,200?
Any way you can do that?
I need some money.
I don't know.
Might be get that seat fixed
and a little cleaned up.
What if just split
the difference?
I think $2000 will cover it.
I believe you
picked the right day.
All right. $2,000.
- Good deal.
Yeah, I got the
tongue right in here.
The tongue is a
wood and metal frame
that connects the
steering axle of the car
to the horse's harness.
Grab the end of it.
Put this together here.
Now let's see if we can
move it up in the road
where you can load
it more easily.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Too tight.
Oh man.
Oh [bleep].
We broke the tongue.
That was kind of
embarrassing, honestly,
to have a tongue
break right there
while I'm making the sale.
Doesn't look too good on me.
I hope that he still wants it.
I'll try to-- I'll
make it right, somehow.
We'll get another
tongue so we can
have a solid tongue for you.
A man doesn't need anything
like that, that's for sure.
- Nope.
- Sorry about that.
It'd be a bad day.
Yeah.
I'll try to get it done
by the end of the day.
Can you come back this evening?
I can come back by here.
From my way back down the road.
- OK.
- All right.
Thank you.
- Yeah.
Well, I'm sorry about that.
- That's all right.
But I'll take care of it.
I've got $2000 on the
line here on this sale,
and I've got to get this tongue
in a satisfactory condition.
And that means I've
got to get to work
here and fix this and make it
so that he's happy with it.
Because if he's
not happy with it,
I'm not going to go
away with $2,000 today,
and I need that for the land.
The broken shaft is
an essential component
that connects the axle
to the horse's harness.
To replace it, Eustace first
separates the broken pieces
from the tongue's
metal framework.
Well, I'm getting it
loose one bolt at a time.
I'm running into a
bit of a problem.
There's a few of
these bolts that
just don't want to come off.
So I need to take a cutting
torch to take them off.
This will get it
so hot, I can blast
the metal right out of there.
The red wrench always works.
To make the repair,
he's scavenging
another wooden shaft of similar
dimensions from his collection.
It looks like it
will fit in there.
I guarantee you that
I'm going to fix it.
Yeah, pays to have a
few scrap pieces around.
That's part of the
deal that we agreed on,
and I'm going to
make sure he has one.
Sweet.
I'm pretty happy with my fix.
I just really hope that
he's happy with it.
I need to walk away with
$2,000 out of this deal.
Hey man, did you
get this fixed up?
I got it all fixed up.
I pulled the tongue
out of another one,
and got one that fit
just right back in there.
I spent a lot of time putting
all this together and getting
a good tongue in there.
He's going to look over
my work and he's going
to make sure it's satisfactory.
I need some money, I
need to buy that lamp.
Might not be the original
tongue, but it's sturdy.
Do the job.
Tongue looks good, Eustace.
Well, I'm glad you like it.
I wanted you to
have something good.
Works for me.
Good deal.
- Good deal.
- Let's get it loaded up.
All right.
This puts me $2,000 closer to
coming up with a down payment.
[inaudible].
Take care, bud.
Thank you.
It's really important to me to
keep this land wild and keep it
natural and buy as much
buffer around my farm
as I possibly can.
But right now, it's just a
hope and a dream and a prayer.